hey youtubers it's Charlie so I have a
Baron Zemo teaser for Captain America
Civil War I'm gonna play it and then I'm
gonna do a breakdown of his history in
the comics but fair warning the teaser
is in German let me see it assess
hydrologic honest test a billion women
that's just of us me fast down menu here
ESMA skansen sure this game
let's Devon Oh cutting gun stock so
fighter Gabriel the first avenge on
Savard
so you all probably know that Daniel
Bruhl is playing Baron Zemo in the movie
but he's not going by Baron Zemo he's
just called Zemo remember is comic book
II as Marvel's gotten with their movies
they're still playing this is a
relatively straightforward political
thriller with just a lot of superhero
stuff going on inside of it so without
giving away any spoilers he's a big part
of the sokovia accords and going after
the Winter Soldier he's trying to learn
about a hit that the Winter Soldier may
have performed in the early 90s which
makes me think that he's going to have
the similar arc to Black Panther whereby
the son takes the mantle of the father
so in the comics there are two big
versions of Baron Zemo one there's
Heinrich Zemo actually debuted in 1964
then later in the comics his son Helmut
took the mantle and became the next
Baron Zemo than in later comics and the
animated series they broaden the
mythology a little bit and just said
that the Baron Zemo title had been
passed down from generation for a long
long time so they're just a dynastic
family just like Baron von strucker's
family I'm going to surrender you delete
everything if we give the Avengers the
weapons they may not look to find to
what we spend the twins they actually
did Baron von strucker's son on agents
of shield if you haven't been watching
that TV show so I think it's the same
thing that's going on in the movie Black
Panther is the Prince of Wakanda but
becomes the king eventually after his
father dies most of the time when you
think of Baron Zemo you think of the
hood that he wears and you think of
masters of evil the special organization
aside from Hydra there's just like a big
villain team-up there have been a bunch
of different incarnations of the Masters
of evil but the first version was
Heinrich Zemo then many years later his
son put another masters of evil team
together and as you can imagine when
they brought his son along they just
they updated a lot of stories typically
the classic Marvel stories tended to be
a little more whimsical like the way
they explained the hood like why does he
wear suit all the time was actually kind
of funny so think back to the first
Captain America film all about world war
ii fighting the Nazis Heinrich Zemo
developed weapons for the Nazi Party but
he wanted to retain a certain level of
anonymity so he started wearing the hood
but then was getting ready to unveil his
latest creation something called
adhesive X and
kind of see where this is going got into
a fight with Captain America doused with
the adhesive X so the masts got stuck to
his face permanently which is kind of
funny when his son came along trying to
take revenge on Captain America for the
death of his father he fell into a vat
of that same adhesive X that his father
got doused in but he wasn't wearing the
mask so the way they explained his son
wearing the mask is that his face just
got hideously scarred when he fell into
the VAT so he started wearing the mask
just to hide the scars you get the idea
comics were growing up a little bit so
some of the twists were a little bit
more hardcore so like his father he went
on a team up with other Hydra villains
like Arnim Zola who we saw during Winter
Soldier later he became leader of the
Thunderbolts and he actually just showed
up during the big Avengers standoff
comic that they're writing right now so
it turns out that shield was actually
trying to use fragments of the Cosmic
Cube it's called the Cosmic Cube in the
comics in the movies is called the
tesseract the way it works in the comics
is a little bit more like the reality
gem of the movies and shield was using a
fragment of it to create this super Jail
this alternate reality where they rehab
forcibly rehab villains long story short
as you'd expect things go to [ __ ] the
villains organized a prison break and
one of them happens to be Baron Zemo who
kind of leads the charge against the
heroes so we're actually in the middle
of that right now but it has nothing to
do with Captain America Civil War so you
don't need to read it to understand
what's going on in the movie here's my
big question for you guys let me know in
the comments though do you hope that at
some point we will see a version of the
masters of evil in the movies now it's a
pretty comic book ii thing so i don't
know if they would necessarily call it
that in the movies but i do think that
we'll eventually get to the point where
there's a big villain team-up
i think they want to keep it relatively
simple now because there's so many
heroes so they're trying to string out
all their villains I think we'll see a
bunch more villains and Infinity Ward
just because there's gonna be so many
characters like you have fan o's in the
Infinity Gauntlet that's gonna be the
biggest problem but usually people like
Hydra try to take advantage of chaos
that's created by stuff like that so
don't be surprised if there are a bunch
of villains an infinity war in addition
to a bunch of heroes
in related news if you guys didn't see
they just introduced the Azrael
character on Gotham I'll totally do a
video for that but I know a lot of you
were confused about the flash last night
and the difference between hunter
zolomon Jay Garrick and the big twist
with the zoom doppelganger so I'll
totally do a video
trying to simplify that while you guys
wait for that video to post you can
click here for last night's episode of
the flash and you can click here to
learn all about Marvel phase 4 thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight